as high-tech covid vaccines have rolled
out in wealthy nations the developing
world has largely been left behind
unable to afford them and unable to
produce them we've done an appalling job
of actually sharing vaccines and
ensuring that the world is vaccinated
it's an urgent problem epidemiologists
have warned the next virus variant could
emerge in a highly unvaccinated
population the way delta and omicron did
we are only going to get in front of
this pandemic and have vaccines widely
available when you have vaccines that
are being
produced locally distributed locally and
are made at scale researchers in texas
have found a way to do just that
developing a vaccine called corbivax
it's based on traditional vaccine
technology that can easily and cheaply
be made almost anywhere we think it's a
game changer many manufacturers can make
it they have all the ecosystems in place
dr maria elena botazi and dr peter hotez
started their vaccine research after the
2003 sars outbreak when kovitt 19
arrived they realized what they had
and then of course when we saw the
sequence we said oh my god this is like
80 percent similar to the tsar sequence
what's more they're making the vaccine
formula free to anyone who wants it no
patents no licenses simply a gift to the
world when you're in a crisis you really
want to do things that are morally
imperative and that you know that you
address the urgency in clinical trials
the two-dose corpora vaxx has proven 80
percent effective against the delta
variant studies into omicron and
boosters are ongoing
in india one manufacturer is already
planning to produce 1.2 billion doses
per year look if you want to develop
vaccines there are for the public good
you need to share your knowledge in
developing their vaccine the researchers
hope they've created a global model for
tackling future diseases one driven by
the need to save as many lives
everywhere as quickly as possible
jackson prosco global news washington